hello and welcome back to our Channel
today we have an exciting video for all
the tech enthusiasts out there we are
going to dive into the future of
artificial intelligence and discuss the
top AI Technologies you should learn in
2024 with AI rapidly evolving staying up
to date with the latest trends and
Technologies is crucial whether you are
a student a professional or just curious
about the future this video is packed
with valuable insights to guide you on
your AI Learning Journey and before we
move on to what the AI Technologies is
if you want to become an AI expert and
gain handsome salary packages look at a
wide range of AI ml courses offered by
simply learn in collaboration with top
universities across the globe by
enrolling in any of these certification
programs you will gain expertise in
skills like generative AI prompt
engineering chat GPD explainable AI
machine learning algorithm supervised
and unsupervised learning model training
and optimization and there's much more
on the list with hands-on experience and
tools like chat jpd Del python open CV
and tensorflow you will catch the eye of
top recruiters so what are you waiting
for hurry up and enroll now and a year
of experience is preferred to enroll in
these courses you can find the course
Link in the description box below and
pin comment so without further Ado let's
jump into the world of AI and explore
the technologies that will shape 2024
and AI is no longer a futuristic concept
it's an integral part of our Lives
driving Innovations across various
Industries whether you are a student
looking to shape your career a
professional looking to stay ahead or
simply an AI Enthusiast this video will
provide you with the road map for the
year ahead now we'll start with the top
AI Technologies and the First Technology
you should be learning in 2024 is deep
learning so deep learning is at the
Forefront of AI advancements it's a
subset of machine learning that employs
neural networks with multiple layers to
simulate the human brain's decision
making processes in 2024 deep learning
is pivotal for various AI applications
from image and speech recognition to
natural language understanding mastering
deep neural networks is essential for
harnessing the power of AI making it a
fundamental technology to delve into for
aspiring AI Enthusiast and professionals
now moving to the next technology that
is natural language processing and NLP
continues to be a rapidly evolving field
learning about NLP techniques including
Transformer models like B and GPT can be
highly valuable especially in
applications like chat boards sentiment
analysis and language translation
natural language processing one of the
leading AI Technologies is set to
reshape communication between humans and
machines in 2024 NLP enables machines to
understand interpret and generate human
language as we delve into the top AI
technologies will explore how NLP is
revolutionizing the way we interact with
computers making it an essential skill
to master in the ever evolving world of
AI now moving to the next technology
that is computer vision computer vision
Technologies are used in applications
like image and video analysis facial
recognition and autonomous vehicles
learning about convolutional neural
networks CNN and object detection
techniques is important in this domain
and in the realm of AI computer vision
stands as a groundbreaking technology it
enables machines to interpret and
understand visual information from the
world much like the human eye and brain
by harnessing Advanced algorithms and
neural networks computer vision empowers
AI systems to analyze images and videos
recognize objects detect patterns and
even interpret emotions from facial
expressions this technology finds
applications in various fields from
autonomous vehicles and medical
Diagnostics to security and augmented
reality making it a vital area to master
in the ever evolving a landscape now
moving to the next technology that is
reinforcement learning so reinforcement
learning is a cutting HEI technology
that's poised to shape 2024 it's all
about training machines to make
sequential decisions in Dynamic
environments in reinforcement learning
an agent learns pacting with its
surroundings and receiving feedback in
the form of Rewards or penalties this
approach has transformative applications
from autonomous robotics to game playing
and even self-driving cars making it a
vital skill to master for AI Enthusiast
and now moving to the next technology
that is generative adversarial networks
G so GN are a groundbreaking AI
technology gns consist of two neural
networks a generator and a discriminator
engaged in a Dynamic competition the
generator creates data while the
discriminator task is to differentiate
between real and generated data this
competition drives the generator to
produce increasingly realistic content
GN have far-reaching applications from
creating lifelike images to enhancing
data synthesis and transformation making
them a pivotal technology in ai's
creative and data generation Realms now
moving to the next technology that is AI
ethics and bias in 2024 when critical AI
technology to focus on it AI ethics and
bias with AI systems playing an
increasingly prominent role in our lives
understanding the ethical applications
and implications and addressing biases
in these systems is Paramount AI ethics
involves designing and deploying AI
algorithms that are fair transparent and
respectful of privacy it aims to ensure
that AI benefits all without
perpetuating discrimination learning how
to mitigate bias and Implement ethical
AI practices is essential for building
responsible and trustworthy AI Solutions
now moving to the next technology that
is explainable AI in the context of the
top AI Technologies to learn in 2024
explainable AI is a critical technology
that focuses on making AI systems
transparent and interpretable xci
enables users to understand how AI
models make decisions providing insights
into their inner workings and this
technology is essential for ensuring
trust and ethical use of AI as it helps
identify and mitigate biases while
making AI more accountable learning xci
in 2024 will be crucial for AI
professionals and researchers to create
responsible and transparent AI Solutions
now moving to the next technology that
is quantum Computing Quantum Computing
is a groundbreaking AI technology that
leverages the principles of quantum
mechanics to perform computations
exponentially faster than traditional
computers in 2024 it promises to
revolutionize AI by solving complex
problems like optimization and
cryptography that were previously
insurmountable quantum computers use
quantum bits or Q bits which can exist
in multiple States simultaneously
enabling unprecedented computational
power as Quantum Computing matures AI
practitioners should consider gaining an
understanding of this transformative
technology to harness its potential for
AI applications now moving to the next
technology that is HGI HGI is a Cutting
Edge technology that enables artificial
intelligence to run locally on devices
like smartphones iot devices and AD
servers rather than relying on
cloud-based processing this empowers
these devices to make real-time
decisions without the need for constant
internet connectivity in 2024 SGI is
expected to become increasingly vital
especially in applications like
autonomous vehicles Industrial
Automation and smart cities with low
latency and immediate processing of data
are critical for success and now moving
to the next technology that is AI and
Healthcare in the field of AI one of the
most promising and impactful areas is AI
and Healthcare this technology harness
the power of artificial intelligence to
revolutionize medical diagnosis drug
Discovery and patient care by analyzing
vast data sets and images AI algorithms
can assist Healthcare Professionals in
making more accurate diagnosis leading
to early intervention and improved
patient outcomes AI in healthcare is set
to transform the medical industry in
2024 offering the potential to save
lives and enhance the quality of
healthcare services and then comes AI in
finance in the context of AI in finance
AI Technologies are revolutionizing the
financial industry machine learning
algorithms and Predictive Analytics are
being used for risk assessment fraud
detection and algorithm trading natural
language processing NLP is employed for
sentiment analysis of financial news and
reports additionally AI driven chat
boards and virtual financial advisers
are providing personalized
recommendations to clients these
advancements enhance efficiency reduce
risk and improve decision making making
AI in finance a critical field to learn
in 2024 and now moving to the last
technology that is AI in cyber security
in the realm of AI Technologies for 2024
AI in cyber security stands out as a
GameChanger this technology harnesses
the power of artificial intelligence to
detect prevent and respond to cyber
threats in real time machine learning
algorithms analyze massive data sets to
identify anomalies and potential
breaches fortifying digital systems and
networks as cyber threats continue to
evolve a in cyber security is becoming
increasingly crucial to protect
sensitive data and maintain digital
resilience and to stay up toate in the
field of AI we recommend following AI
conferences reading research papers and
enrolling in online courses and
certification programs related to the
specific areas that interest you
additionally a is a diverse field and
the best technology to learn may depend
on your personal interest and career
goals and that's a ref for today's video
we hope you find this information on the
top AI Technologies to learn in 2024
both informative and inspiring the AI
landscape is continually involving and
staying ahead of the curve can open up
incredible opportunities if you enjoyed
this video don't forget to give it a
thumbs up and subscribe for more
exciting content feel free to share your
thoughts in the comment section below
and let us know which AI technology you
are most excited to learn in 2024 thank
you for joining us today and we'll see
you in the next video Stay curious and
keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in collabor
oration with leading universities and
top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here oh